هناك أنواع مختلفة من
القواعد العسكرية، هناك
القاعدة العسكرية التي يعرفها الجميع،
يمكنك أن تقول Camp Lun um في
ولاية كارولينا الجنوبية أو شيء من هذا القبيل أو ولاية كارولينا الشمالية
في الولايات المتحدة وما إلى ذلك، ثم
هناك أعتقد أن المصطلح الفني  في
الواقع هي قواعد رمادية أه وهي
مجرد مصطلح فني يعني شيئًا
لم يتم نشره حقًا ولكن لا
يعتبر سريًا، ثم
موقع أسود وهو مصطلح من المحتمل أن يكون الجمهور قد
سمع عنه يشير في الواقع إلى
مصطلح فني آخر لما  من
المفترض أن تكون
منشآت سرية غير معروفة وغير مكتشفة، ويبدو لي أن
الموقع
512 أه هو ما سيندرج تحت
القاعدة الرمادية الثالثة أه، لذا هذا ما يبدو
أه وليس كما أه
موجة التقارير الحالية تصفه بأنه أ
القاعدة السرية هي في الواقع
شيء لا يتم الحديث
عنه علنًا حتى لا يتم لفت الانتباه
إليه بدلاً من السر السري
السؤال كما أفهمه هل القاعدة
512 لها علاقة بالقتال أو
ستتورط فيه أه و
الأزمة في غزة ولا أعلم لكنها على
بعد 30 كيلومتر فقط أه هي
قاعدة عسكرية وهو أه هناك
تواجد أمريكي هناك أعتقد أنه حوالي 100
شخص فإذا إيران أه تم جرها إلى
الصراع ش  بشكل مباشر أكثر يمكن أن يكون ذلك
كارثيًا على العالم ليس فقط على
إسرائيل أو إيران أو الغزيين أه أو حماس
ولكن على نطاق أوسع بكثير يمكن إضفاء
الطابع الإقليمي على الأقل إضفاء الطابع الإقليمي على
الحرب التي تنطوي على قرارات ضخمة
أه الدول العربية الإسلامية التي تعيش في
سلام معها  إسرائيل لذلك لا نعرف ما الذي
سيحدث أعتقد أنه من غير المرجح أن
تكون الولايات المتحدة واضحة صراحة
بإرسال قواتها التي
لا تريدها في الواقع ولا تريد أن
يمتد الصراع إلى ما هو أبعد من أه الرعب في
غزة